حيث اوردت وكاله رويترز ان ما تعرف بقوه
سوريا ديمقراطيه اعلنت تعليق التنسيق
والعمليات المشتركه مع التحالف الدولي
بقياده الولايات المتحده بعد القصف
التركيه
الجيش تركيا المتمرده في ريف حلب قد
استهدفت مواقع لما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه في قرى عده في محيط عين العرب
كوباني حلب شماليه سوريا كما افادت مصادر
الجزيره بتعرض نقاط اخرى لما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه لقصف من قبل الجيش
التركي في خمس قرن غربه الابيض بريف الرقه
بدورها قالت وسائل اعلام كرديه ان طائرات
المسيره التركيه قصفت عده قرى في محيط عين
عيسى بريفي الحسكه
وزاره الدفاع التركيه قالت ان المعركه ضد
الارهابيين الشمالي سوريا ساتستمر بشكل
فعالوى حسن وكان مجلس الامن القومي
تتخذ الخطوات اللازمه لعدم السماح بوجود
اي نشاط لاي تنظيم ارهابي في المنطقه حسب
تعبيره
داخل وخارج البلاد واكد مناقشه التدابير
الاضافيه الممكنه بهذا الصدق